اكدت مصادر قضائيه وحقوقيه للجزيره ان
نيابه العامه التونسيه اذنت بفتح تحقيق
قضائي مع 25 شخصا من بينهم شخصيات اعلاميه
وسياسيه ومسؤولون سابقون بتهمه التامر على
امن الدوله الداخلي والتخابر مع جهات
اجنبيه ومن بين المعنيين بالتحقيق مديره
ديوان الرئاسيه المستقله ناديه عكاشه
ورئيس حزب افاق تونس فاضل عبد الكافي وفقه
وثيقه مسربه تداولها او تداولتها وسائل
الاعلام المحليه وفي حين ناكدت مصادر اخرى
للجزيره ان القضيه تتعلق بتسهيلات الماليه
واداريه غير قانونيه استفادت منها شركه
مختصه في الرهانات الرياضيه تنشط بتونس
وذلك ما يفسر وجود اسم اجنبيه من ضمن
المشمولينا بالتحقيق وفقا المصادر المقابل
لم تعلن السلطات القضائيه التونسيه بشكل
رسمي عن تفاصيل هذه القضيه ومدى صحه
الوثيقه المسربه